Eh salut ça va ?
Alors les vacances ? Bien ou bien ?
Bien ? Tant mieux.
Parce que c'est fini.
Va falloir retourner à la mine, c'est sûrement pas de gaieté de coeur, c'est même peut-être un petit peu stressant
et ça va sans doute vous causer des désordres de type digestifs si vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
[Générique] - Tout l'été, DTC vous aide à éviter les pièges et les dangers qui menacent votre bien-être--
[Julien] - Bah... Bah nan ! Non, non MAIS NON !
Mais non Romain c'est fini l'été hein, les vacances, tout ça c'est terminé, c'est la rentrée justement, tu suis un peu ?
DTC, partenaire de votre rentrée.
Quand on reprend le chemin de l'école, du collège, du lycée, du boulot,
ou de quoi que ce soit qu'on avait arrêté de faire pendant les vacances,
quand il faut y retourner donc, en plus de pas forcément être ravi-ravi, ça peut arriver qu'on soit un poil anxieux,
qu'on ait la boule au ventre comme on dit.
Sauf que la boule au ventre, quand elle sort, elle a plus trop une forme de boule justement.
J'crois qu'on se comprend ?
C'est un fait, le stress donne la diarrhée, phénomène également connu sous le nom scientifique de :
la chiasse, la drouille, la courante, la déripette, la cliche, chier en spray, l’intégrale d'Ève Angeli-
Quand vous êtes stressé, votre corps le sent et il va tout raconter à votre hypothalamus.
Alors "hypothalamus" c'est pas une chaîne de restauration à base de grillades hein,
c'est un petit coin de votre cerveau qui pèse 4 grammes, mais qui pèse quand même extrêmement lourd dans le système nerveux game
Pour se défendre contre ce qui est perçu comme une menace, votre organisme va se mettre en mode commando.
Bon comme il connaît pas la nature exacte du danger, dans le doute il va activer tout un tas de mécanismes
pour se mettre en condition idéale pour le combattre ou pour s'enfuir.
Ouais, votre corps il est un peu drama. C'est juste la rentrée, lui il envoie Vigipirate.
Le jugez pas hein, ça part d'une bonne intention.
Puis c'est pour votre bien.
Bon mais ce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est la digestion.
Elle est gérée par le système nerveux autonome et elle va être touchée principalement par deux phénomènes :
d'abord comme il se sent menacé, votre organisme va donner la priorité aux organes qui peuvent vraiment lui être utile,
comme votre cerveau ou vos muscles,
au détriment d'autres organes qui servent à rien, comme votre estomac.
La digestion ça demande beaucoup d'énergie, y'en a besoin ailleurs,
et puis toutes façons c'est vraiment pas le moment de bouffer.
Alors hop, on met tout ça sur pause pour le moment, du coup l'estomac ne se vide plus,
c'est ce qui explique que vous êtes peut-être l'appétit coupé, voire une petite envie de vomir.
Et une fois que c'est coupé là-haut,
figurez vous que votre organisme se met en tête de faire un peu de place en bas.
Dans l'esprit de votre organisme,
qui en fait des caisses, hein, rappelons-le,
il va falloir fuir ou combattre la cause du stress.
Du coup on est d'accord que ça va pas être le moment d'aller faire caca.
"Ah merde c'est maintenant là ? Ah non mais ça n'arrange pas chef là je..."
"Non bah... Allez-y sans moi parce que je vais vous ralentir." *prrrt*
Donc pour éviter d'avoir envie de crotter au plus mauvais moment,
votre corps décide de faire la vidange.
Et en réalité c'est hyper facile à faire, parce que vos intestins,
c'est pas juste un tuyau d'évacuation passif.
Vos intestins, ils ont une activité qui s'appelle le péristaltisme.
Alors c'est pas une discipline olympique le péristaltisme,
c'est le mouvement que font vos intestins pour faire progresser le caca vers la sortie
et ça ressemble à peu près à ça :
Donc en l'occurrence il suffit d'accélérer le péristaltisme pour prier les matières fécales d'évacuer les lieux.
- Sors, sors, sors, sors !
Bon alors OK ça sort vite, mais pourquoi ça sort mou ?
Ca sort mou voire liquide parce qu'au début de leur grand voyage vos matières fécales elles sont chargées d'eau,
et elles s'en débarrassent normalement tout au long de leur road trip.
Du coup en cas de stress, comme le voyage est beaucoup plus rapide,
il y a moins de temps pour que l'eau soit absorbée,
résultat quand votre caca sort, il est encore plein de flotte, donc il est tout mou
voire franchement liquide.
Malheureusement dans ces cas-là se bourrer des médicaments habituels ça sert pas à grand-chose,
et ça risque même de vous coller une bonne constipation en guise de retour de bâton.
Mangez léger, mangez sain, et attaquez-vous plutôt à la racine du mal :
le stress.
Pour ça vous pouvez faire quelques exercices de respiration abdominale pour vous détendre par exemple.
Attention la respiration abdominale,  ça veut pas dire respirer par le bas hein.
D'ailleurs dans ces circonstances, prenez pas trop la confiance.
Évitez de ventiler par là.
Mon conseil : ne surestimez jamais vos sphincters.
Je vous explique : au niveau de l'anus on est équipés de petits muscles en cercle qui entourent le conduit
pour empêcher les selles de sortir à des moments inopportuns :
ce sont les fameux sphincters.
Alors il y a le sphincter interne qui est contrôlé par le système nerveux autonome,
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne maîtrise pas,
et à l'inverse le sphincter externe qui nous sert à serrer les fesses comme on dit.
Sauf qu'en vrai on est d'accord, on sert pas les fesses. On serre juste l'anus.
Et justement parfois quand on est ballonné, on peut décider de desserrer un petit peu son sphincter pour relâcher la pression.
Dans ces cas-là ça s'ouvre un tout petit peu, juste assez pour laisser passer les gaz,
mais pas trop pour garder les selles normales à l'intérieur.
Mais voilà là pour le coup comme on l'a vu, les selles, elles sont pas normales, elles sont molles voire liquides
et du coup elles arrivent à s' enfuir..
Et là c'est le drame.
Bon pour être pragmatique, la règle absolue, c'est si vous êtes stressé, si vous êtes fragile à ce niveau là :
NE PÉTEZ SOUS AUCUN PRÉTEXTE !
D'abord, péter un jour de rentrée, ça fait tâche
et puis ensuite bah... Ca risque de vraiment faire tache.
Voilà DTC c'est comme l'été, c'est fini pour cette fois, mais ne vous inquiétez pas,
ça va revenir vite, ça va même revenir très vite parce que pour moi aussi c'est la rentrée...
Deux secondes.
La semaine prochaine,
retour à la normale pour une nouvelle saison de DTC avec plein de surprises mais ça on va en reparler plus tard, en attendant,
bonne rentrée et portez vous bien !